okay so movies at the moment are in a
bit of a weird place franchises are
hitting points now where we've had a
number of different actors playing
certain roles that people have fond
memories of from their childhood you
also have technology hitting a point
where it's possible to create lifelike
looking CGI people and this has been
done to great effect in things like the
book of Boba Fett however with this
comes the Temptation that we can now
resurrect the dead and use them in films
to score Cameo points by banking off the
back of nostalgia now I get why Studios
have decided to do it and a lot of the
time it acts as a touching tribute to
those we've lost since we fell in love
with the franchise I know you probably
think this video is gonna be me just
patronizingly condemning them for doing
it but I actually think I can totally
understand why they've done it and a lot
of the times I don't think there's a
nefarious side to it a lot of the
creatives probably think it's a good way
to show an actor lives on in our hearts
through them reprising certain roles and
it doesn't seem that Sinister however I
also now feel it's gotten to the point
where Hollywood spends so much effort on
asking whether they could do it that
they haven't stopped a thing whether
they should throughout this video I want
to go through my personal thoughts on
bringing back their actors and why I
think that in the end Hollywood should
stop doing it this includes at times
where I think it's worked and also the
times where I think it hasn't overall
though I believe we're getting to a
point now where it's too risky to even
attempt this stuff and you should just
avoid doing it because it's rare it
actually works well this video will
contain spoilers for The Flash as well
so if you haven't seen that and don't
want to know then go watch it come back
and let me know what you think now
though the term deep faking is a pretty
New Concept the idea of editing dead
actors into movies is something that's
existed for a long time there's loads of
really notable instances where this has
happened but the first major version
that Springs to mind is Bruce Lee's Game
of Death Lee passed away while only half
of the movie was complete unless the
crew had to come up with their own way
to finish the film CGI obviously wasn't
available at the time and thus they had
to employ body doubles and also edit
things in using existing footage this
allowed them to complete the movie
however this early film also cements
some of the most Sinister things that
could happen when you're trying to bring
an actor back to life in the film we get
a funeral scene involving these
character and they actually used shots
of the Dead actor from his open casket
ceremony YouTube is being a bit funny
with monetization at the moment and I
don't want to show a body like this on
screen because you know what happened
with Logan Paul but if you watch the
movie his actual corpse is there now in
the context of the film it's used when
the character fakes his death however
filming is open casket for a moment like
this it's not exactly something I can
doubt and that was a kind of exemplifies
some of my issues with what we'll get
into and it becomes more about making
the movie than it does about respecting
the actor one of the best things I think
Marvel did with wakanda forever is that
they didn't tell out a CGI Chadwick
Boseman to die at some point in the
movie though people don't like the
funeral aspect of the film I think it
works well as a tribute and we of course
have the Marvel Studios logo being
changed to a homage of him that to me
still works well in giving the fans a
feeling they're saying goodbye without
trying to resurrect the dead for a
couple of minutes of footage now the
whole thing with Bruce Lee is something
that Studios have implied when an acted
eyes mid production his son Brandon Lee
sadly died during his work on the crow
when they had to rewrite and use doubles
in order to complete the work Oliver
Reed had to have certain scenes edited
differently Gladiator and they reuse
certain shots and lines to make it see
me was still alive I think things like
this are okay as the actor signed on and
likely wanted to finish the film if they
couldn't be there to do it as technology
has improved though all the advancements
in ways that they panel things have also
changed as well I think Paul Walker's
passing exemplifies this and the actor
sadly died during the filming of furious
7. his brothers were brought on to film
the body double shots and they digitally
replaced his face at the end for that
final write-off into the sunset it
seemed to me is extremely touching and
it acts as a great tribute to the
deceased actor now this is where I think
things work well as Paul obviously
wanted to be part of the movie but he
unfortunately couldn't film it where
things start to get murky for me though
is when actors are brought back that
haven't given their consent now in the
case of Ghostbusters after life Harold
Ramis was recreated through using CGI to
play Egon come the Final Act of the film
why I think this works okay on a moral
level is that ramus was trying to get
the movie off the ground for a number of
years but he sadly passed away but
before it rolled into production the
film itself also acts as a tribute to
him with several other characters
locations and so on or being linked
directly to Egon you also have the Rifts
between the cast and this sadly caused
them to not be on speaking terms for a
number of years Bell Murray and Harold
had a big falling out which was highly
reported on though they did patch things
up before his passing this is sort of
all the characters finally saying they
goodbye to not only Egon but Harold as
well and we're very much getting some
meta commentary from the actors who
apologize for not reaching out now where
I think things start to get a bit
murkier it is in stuff like Rogue one
where they bring back talking they
already tied around with this in Revenge
of the Sith by showing a younger vision
of him but this was played by a
different actor so no harm no foul
personally I think recasts like this are
fine as you can't expect people to stay
in the role forever where we hit the
Shades of Gray though is when he's
brought back as a character in the movie
now the main thing with this that
doesn't appear in the other things we'll
talk about later on is that talking
actually has a character he doesn't says
things that massively impact the plot
and doesn't feel like they've just
thrown him in there to silently stand
around there's an actor playing him and
the creative team clearly put a lot of
effort into making sure the effects were
as good as they could be and that they
would bring him back in the best way
that they could I know people kick off
our Lair at the end of the movie but
this was made before Carrie Fisher's
passing and I'd consider that more of a
deep fake de-aging sort of thing she was
brought back using archival footage for
Rise of Skywalker but she's integral to
the plot in that and obviously was
hoping to be around when they made that
movie anyway that's where things start
to really bend a lot and hey if you're
mad at talking coming back then I can
totally understand now at the opposite
end of this is what we get in the Flash
and this is where I've hit a point where
I wish Hollywood would stop doing it in
the film there's a big scene that brings
back a number of dead actors including
George Reeves Christopher Reeve and Adam
West none of these characters say
anything they don't affect the plot at
all and instead they're just propped up
like puppets so we can point at the
screen and applaud the CGI has also been
really mishandled when it comes to this
and they don't look like there's been
that much ever put into them I know the
term PlayStation 3 Graphics it's thrown
around but they just look dead-eyed and
not like real people and I'll direct
Andy machete has also come out and said
these bad effects were intentional but I
think they should have chosen someone
else or just scrap them entirely they
have no bearing on the plot and it's not
like the Studio's hands were tied with
this similar to something like rise of
Skywalker they really didn't need to be
included in the film and instead it
feels like they were just put in so they
could trick us into feeling nostalgic
about it had they helped stop the worlds
crashing into each other and might be a
little less frustrated with it but they
don't do anything beyond just standing
around now if you know the history of
some of the people here as well then you
know why this might be seen as being in
bad taste George Reeve ended up sinking
into a depression about how much
Superman ruined his career and the actor
apparently took his own life after
failing defined other roles there are
conspiracies about whether that's the
case or not but the mental anguish he
felt is at least very well documented
it's also the fact that these guys
didn't give their consent or have any
involvement at all with this film in the
case of Carrie Fisher she of course
filmed things for the force awakens and
Last Jedi that could then be reworked
for Rye so the character get a send off
you know there's no way when George
Reeve signed on that he could have
imagined the DCU or even thought of a
way his likeness could have been used in
the future sure states can sign things
off but ask yourself yeah if you had a
great great nephew that are great to let
you be put in a movie after you died do
you think they'd be doing it because you
know they have a strong personal
connection to you or because there's
also some Financial incentive I'm sure
there's aspects of the first part but
yeah the people signing off on this
stuff might not have everyone's best
interests at heart George Reeve didn't
have any children either so there are
questions over how this Cameo came about
now I think the fact that they don't
really do anything also cheapens the
tribute overall a getting called cameos
but when you think about it they're not
really cameos for example I could quite
easily use today's technology to make an
AI Recreation of William Shakespeare
that I then take and put into a video
Shakespeare never gave his consent it's
not really him I just have him flashing
on screen for a second and he has
absolutely had no involvement at all
what I'm doing is I'm just showing a CGI
version of him which by the same rules
means that he's come here in my video he
hasn't but you get the idea and can
hopefully Now understand why that's the
same case with the movie I think when
you have so many actors attached to
tragedy that appear like this and mean
absolutely nothing to the plot that's
when things get bad and also the effects
in general don't look good either
instead of being wowed I'm sat thinking
how atrocious it looks which makes me
feel like it's a bit of a bad tribute
when all things are considered feels
like when they unveil a bad statue of
someone and instead of being something
you Marvel at it just looks so bad and
has the complete opposite effect now
like I said I'm not trying to get too
preachy on this stuff I apologize if
I've come across that way as I can
actually see why they've started to do
it more and more and more however I
think the risks outweigh the benefits of
doing it and in the end there's a lot
that can go wrong Brandon Routh
canonically is the same version as
Christopher Reeve and I don't think
there would have been any of the
backlash if he'd been in the role
instead what we have though is leaked
frames in footage blowing up on Twitter
and now people writing 10 minute long
video essays asking them to stop doing
it I think that Hollywood should just
let the dead lie and probably put an end
to this before it gets out of control it
almost feels like the corporations now
only act as even in death and that
they'll just keep Wheeling them out for
eternity without ever letting them rest
kinda sounds like the plot of a Black
Mirror episode and if you've seen Jonas
awful then you'll know it touches on a
similar thing I was actually watching
that thinking they might have released
it on the same day as the flash on
purpose because they even do a joke
about George Clooney in it at one point
either way though what I'm asking
Hollywood is that you please think about
it the next time you try my guess is
that you'll realize you often don't need
to do this and that you're only doing it
for nostalgic reasons I think when
you're in a position of thinking should
I do this should I not the fact you're
questioning it probably shows that you
you unsure yourself and it's best to
just play it safe don't do it and you'll
get none of these negative feelings
towards your film and instead people can
enjoy for its plot story and
performances obviously I know this is
going to be a touchy subject so if you
agree or not then the comment sections
below hopefully I've argued my points
across to where you can at least see why
I'm talking about this and I'd of course
also love to hear your perspective too
we'll leave some other videos on screen
right now if you want to watch them and
hopefully I see you over there right
after this but out of the way I've been
your host Paul hopefully this has given
you something to think about and
hopefully I'll see you on the next video
you take care yourself peace